the duchess of sussex has won her high
court privacy claim against the mail on
sunday over the publication of a
personal and private
handwritten letter to her estranged
father meghan markle said in a statement
that she was grateful that associated
newspapers
and the mail on sunday had been held to
account
sky's royal correspondent rihanna mills
joins me now so
rihanna on the face of it a big win this
for meghan markle
this will be seen as a huge victory by
the sussexes this evening who
over recent years have made it very
clear that they would
hold those to account that they felt
over the years have
victimized them have run untrue stories
about them and this evening we found out
that mr justice warby who is the judge
who's been overseeing this case between
megan
and associated newspapers has ruled in
her favor and allowed the fact that this
will not
go to trial he has decided that she has
won
her case now if i read out her statement
to you i think it shows just how
pleased they are with that verdict this
evening the duchess of sussex has said
after two long years of pursuing
litigation i'm grateful to the courts
for holding associated newspapers and
the mail on sunday to account
for their illegal and dehumanizing
practices
these tactics and those of their sister
publications mail online and the daily
mail
are not new in fact they've been going
on for far too long
without consequence for these outlets
it's a game
for me and so many others it's real life
real relationships and very real sadness
the damage they've done and continue to
do runs deep
she goes on to say i share this victory
with each of you
because we all deserve justice and truth
and we all
deserve better now just to remind
everyone this case
revolved around a letter that was
published by the mail on sunday in
february
2019 a letter that megan had written to
her father
talking about the upset that he'd caused
by sharing
personal details about their
relationship by talking to various
newspapers now
megan's father all along said that he
went to the newspaper with that letter
because megan's friends had previously
talked about that letter
in an interview that they had done with
people magazine
however mr justice warby today has said
the claimant still had
a reasonable expectation that the
contents of that letter
would uh remain private he said the only
terrible justification for any such
interference
was to correct some inaccuracies about
the letter but he says for the most part
they did not serve that purpose at all
taken as a whole the disclosures were
manifestly excessive
and hence unlawful now the managing
editor of the mail on sunday robin kelly
has responded this evening
by saying that we're very surprised by
today's summary judgment
and disappointed of being denied the
chance to have all the evidence
heard and tested in open court at a full
trial
they say we're carefully considering the
judgement contents
and will decide in due course whether to
lodge
an appeal now it is worth pointing out
the judge said there is one
element to this case that should
potentially still go to trial
and that is around copyright who exactly
owns the copyright because there is a
suggestion
that actually megan was helped by some
palace staff when it came to writing
that letter but certainly i think
the sussexes will be breathing a sigh of
relief they wanted to avoid
a huge show trial where you would have
father and daughter giving evidence
against each other and that is something
that they have managed to avoid
and i think also sending a clear message
to the tabloids that they will not
put up with stories that they say are
inaccurate and false
yeah and just briefly rhiannon the
background is the couple's
difficult very difficult relationship
with the press
oh yeah i will never forget the end of
that tour in south africa where it was
announced that megan was going to take
this
legal action against the mail on sunday
and the accompanying statement that we
had from prince harry
a 10-paragraph statement in which he
alluded to
the fact that he believes that stories
that were written about his mother the
way that the tabloids and the paparazzi
pursued her eventually led to her death
in some way and the fact that he said
that he was not going to allow that to
happen
to another woman in his life he of
course has been fiercely protective
of megan and also his son archie only
last week we also saw him
uh prince harry win uh his court battle
against
again the mail on sunday uh for claiming
that he had not been in contact
with the royal marines of course this is
completely different from what we'd
usually expect from mems the royal
family who have that mantra
of never complain never explained but
certainly the sussexes are very
different they are definitely
convinced that they will take things to
court if they think that they have
a case to pursue and this evening they
will be
feeling some sense of relief that in
some ways this brings to
to an end what they call two years a
very difficult litigation
um but yeah they are not afraid to take
on those who they feel
and not writing the correct things about
them and
are intruding into their privacy too
much